pop superstar Michael Jackson stands
accused of being a predatory serial
pedophile radio stations across the
world are now reluctant to play as music
yet his fans continue to defend him
posters appeared on the side of buses
Barbra Streisand said the kids were
thrilled to be at Neverland while Diana
Ross even tweeted that Jackson was a
magnificent incredible force and pleaded
stop in the name of love so I have to
ask do the singers fans have a point
Michael Jackson's defenders argue that
some of the shame stems from the
societal taboo and not from the act
themselves they're wrong and I do not
defend his actions in the slightest
pedophilia is a crime whether it's
perpetrated by the King of Pop in a
magical ranch or a prep school master
but I would say this however flawed he
was as a man they are right to point out
he was or is still a great artist and I
see no shame in continuing to listen and
admire his work I'm almost going to
argue against myself because I always
think that people should could only be
convicted if they've had a trial and
he's never actually been convicted of
any of these charges
however Rachel I can never listen to his
music in the same way again I don't
believe in censoring I really don't I'm
not going to and there are so many
musicians artists authors down the years
who have had very questionable powers
that a tiny bit you can never listen to
it in the same way because it's as it
were being toxified by the fact that you
know what I did but do you agree that
his body of work stands as a body of
work such as you know Varga was an
anti-semite can you listen to Vaughn I
can't do that and for those viewers who
not up to speed much of this focuses on
a documentary which is child leaving
Neverland and let's see something from
that
today is your birthday so
congratulations I love you goodbye
there's no thoughts of this is wrong or
anything like that told me if they ever
found out what we were doing he and I
would go to jail for the rest of our
lives
secrets will eat you up you feel so
alone I want to be able to speak the
truth as loud as I had to speak the lie
for so long
that's from leaving Neverland it starts
if the viewer didn't quite at hello Wade
and that refers to Wade Robson who with
James safe chuckers two men who've made
these claims but all I would say before
I yield is it seems extraordinary that a
grown man would seek to take young boys
and sleep with a minister I find that
really really strange but again you'll
point to musicians and/or law and
authors I'm sure you're right and
composers and all sorts of other people
that strikes ministration also he didn't
pay or his estate didn't pay off one
young person they didn't pay off there's
a history of paying off boys and all
their families that to me means it asks
you a question I don't want to censor it
but if I never hear another Michael
Jackson song until the day I die I won't
be missing anything what do we think can
we separate the art from the artist no I
got I can't either
and I blame myself partly for because
you know years ago he was almost SOTA
Graff holding a child a boy's hand he
was always your children and all his
videos why did why didn't we get it back
then maybe it was because we thought he
couldn't be so blatant and be abusing
children in plain sight of the world and
also it was part of me thought well you
know the parents wouldn't leave their
kids with him if that's what if that's
what was happening but but I and I think
we all have to take a little bit of
blame for this because you know one of
the one of it no because because he
wasn't pursued in the way he should have
done he should have been a pistol he was
he was what he paid off for some people
as you know he did go to court over one
case but you know the world watched him
do this in the same way we watched Jimmy
Savile the rumors were there he's
America's Jimmy Savile and I am I and
one of the one of the comments from the
kids I think was Wade Robson he said MJ
was the kindest
loving person I ever knew but he was
abusing me for seven years and you see
what happened to these kids with that
it's tragic and and [ __ ] someone like
Barbra Streisand who I adored I mean
really for her to say stuff like can we
can't can I just tell everybody in case
they'd forgotten I was gonna Celeste its
Bob
Streisand actually said his sexual needs
were were his sexual needs coming from
whatever childhood he has or whatever
DNA he has you can say molested but
those children they were thrilled to be
there they both married and they both
have children so it didn't kill them but
she did later recant and said to be
clear there is no situation or
circumstance where it is okay for the
innocence of children to be taken
advantage of by anyone I am profoundly
sorry for any pain or misunderstanding I
caused by not choosing my words more
carefully about Michael Jackson offer do
you think carol has a point in saying
that too on one level we all knew for
decades that Michael Jackson was herb
Lisa but we all continued to listen to
his songs to download them Spotify still
records 22 million users a month and
listening to Michael Jackson's tracks
I find this a really difficult topic I
bet those comments and Brock Barbra
Streisand made me feel sick you should
never seek to justify child abuse and
I'm not ambivalent about that I don't
think I'm not comfortable any of these
tweets saying well there's no evidence
that these men at you know people who
were victims historic sex abuse struggle
to prove it through tangible evidence
they should always be taken seriously so
I feel that very strongly I grew up with
Michael Jackson some of my first words
for Michael Jackson lyrics as a
two-year-old I was obsessed if my whole
childhood fine for Michael Jackson he's
the soundtrack to my childhood and it's
very very painful for me to hear this
about him and you know I'm music when I
saw him with children I was a child and
wanted to be in netherland you know that
was my dream to be like those boys at
the time I was the same age as them so
it's really difficult for me and I think
you know the lawyer in me says he has
not been convicted of an offense we have
preserved a presumption of innocence for
reason that's not dismissing or
belittling the claims of the abusers but
I'm uncomfortable with this kind of
summary judgment that he's cancer
when he's not being convicted on the
other hand she talks about your
emotional reaction okay breathe even
though he's paid tens of millions of
pounds to these children and to their
families can I another Lord I just can I
just let you hear what Taj Jackson says
about it is here uncle that city knows
I'm okay
I was you know in that environment I was
a kid as well but you know it's hard for
me to say a grown man and you know my
uncle was a child at heart you know but
he didn't have a normal childhood and
everyone that knew him you know from
Elizabeth Taylor to Whoopi Goldberg to
Macaulay Culkin the ones that he let in
they recognized that and I think it's
it's hard for me to say because I know
as a parent you know you look at it
differently you know like that there's
no way that that should happen period in
terms of just childhood he just he was
looking for that companionship and not
in a sexual way just in a friendship way
just before you come in Karen I think I
think it's healthy to have this
conversation not just about him but
about other artists I mean look at Erick
Gill his sculptures on the front of the
BBC we use his fonts on a daily basis he
was abusing his daughters well he made
art about them there are lots of people
whose work we admire who were very
problematic I don't think that we should
exonerate them I don't think we should
silent it sounds like I haven't said
anything to justify it they happen I'm
just saying and I think this reflects
what many people feel especially those
who grew up with him or emotionally
attached to his music that it's very
difficult and painful conversation that
they forget that in 2005 there was a
huge trial and which everyone expected
him yeah to actually go to jail and he
got off scot-free and the prosecutors at
that time were just completely surprised
because they thought it was overwhelming
so he has never been convicted there's
no question about it they got off
scot-free of course he might have
innocent characters he was convicted
that's reality
radios should carry on here's the other
thing after he died the wreck his record
sales have been more
during his lifetime before I mean
Sonia's continued to point 1 billion
pounds has been made since his death
from his music which is incredible
figure so what are the family saying
Michael was subjected to a thorough
investigation which included a surprise
raid of Neverland and other properties
as well as a jury trial where Michael
was found to be completely innocent we
can't just stand by while this public
lynching goes on and the vulture
tweeters and others who never met
Michael go after Michaels not here to
defend himself otherwise these
allegations would not have been made the
Jackson family goes on Michael Jackson
was and always will be 100% innocent of
these false allegations quickly around
the table you're running a radio station
you play the music or not yes I would
and I would say what the Jackson family
should have said was we believe we
believe he did bad things but he still
was our son and our brilliant artist and
that remains yes the reality is his
music is gonna carry on mcclain I'm not
a great fan of his music at all but I'm
gonna have to listen to it because it's
gonna be played you're running radio
stations would you continue to play as
music absolutely not because I think we
have to make clear that that kind of
behavior is not acceptable at all ever
pass which means yes I struggle I seek
her I haven't made up my mind I read
because he was a murderer you weren't
listen to vogner because he was an
anti-semite you're why does this stop
the music stops right now because you're
watching the pledge on Sky News and
coming up good four more years
[Music]